اعلنت وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه عن سقوط
200 قتيل خلال الاحداث الاخيره التي شهدت
ايران ويشمل العدد القتلى عناصر قوات
الامن والمدنيين الذين قتلوا خلال ما
وصفته بالهجمات الارهابيه
والاضطرابات الامنيه التي شهدتها مدن
ايرانيه اضافه الى عناصر من جماعات
المسلحه وانفصاليه اضاف البيان انما
شاهدته البلاد لم تكن احتجاجات سلميه بل
عمليات تخريب تهدف لزعزعه الامن ونشر
العنف واكد البيان الحصول عمليات تهريب
بكميات كبيره من السلاح الى ايران لتوسيع
دائره ما وصفتها بالعمليات الارهابيه
قال رئيس الايراني وابراهيم الرئيسي نما
وصفها بالاطراف سالتي تدعي انها تدافع عن
حقوق الانسان والديمقراطيه الليبراليه
تدعم دول لم تشهد اي انتخابات في تاريخها
وتحقد على بلاده التي تجري فيها انتخابات
الانتخابات بعدد السنوات التي مرت بعد
انتصاره الثوره الاسلاميه في ايران
حقوق الانسان
والدكتاتوريه تعقد على ايران الدوله التي
تعتبر من اكثر الدول التي تستند الى اراء
الناس كيف يعقل ان يصدق هذا الامر الدستور
عندما يؤكد ويظهر احتراما حقوق الانسان في
البلاد
الاعداده هي الامر الثابت في الدستور